Who will be the Democratic nominee for
Nevada Attorney General? Nicole
Cannizzaro has been a chief deputy
district attorney in Clark County and is
one of the most powerful state
legislators in the Senate since 2016,
majority leader since 2019.
>> Everything from affordable and
accessible health care
to enforcing and supporting public
education and teachers
and to supporting voting rights and of
course a lot of work to uplift
reproductive health care at
>> Zach Conine has been elected statewide
as Nevada's treasurer since 2019,
overseeing the state's finances and
investments.
>> We've got to keep building affordable
housing and a big piece of affordable
housing is fairness, leveling the
playing field and making sure that all
Nevadans, whether they're large or small
companies, whether they're just
individuals, have a fair shot of being
successful.
>> Both found to be a stalwart against the
Trump administration.
>> I took down gangs and fraudsters, so I
know his [music] type.
>> There are attacks on our right to vote,
there are attacks on our reproductive
health care and our freedoms and we
really need somebody who understands
those battles and is ready to take them
on.
>> With Donald Trump, there's a new fight
every day.
>> anything I want.
>> We have to fight back against this
federal overreach and I've been doing
that each and every day in the treasury.
We're the ones arguing with DOE, we're
the ones noticing when the federal
government doesn't pay its bills.
>> But differences and attacks have emerged
when you more closely examine their
records in public life.
>> What I bring is that experience doing
both civil and criminal litigation. I'm
the candidate in the race in the primary
that I am in who has any sort of
courtroom legal experience.
>> You know, my opponent in this race
actually passed a bill that allows for
NV Energy to raise rates out of cycle.
This whole demand charge thing that
we're seeing right now, that came from
her.
>> Conine's Q1 fundraising, including PAC
money, was 1.3 million compared to
Cannizzaro's $300,000.
Much of Conine's fundraising, 2.5
million so far in total, has come from
one person, cryptocurrency mogul Jeff
Berns.